thank you so much nate buenos iris air
conditioning and heating owner carlos
ava maria
is back to tell us how his dream
continues to keep the valley's families
and businesses
cool and clean and at ease it's that
simple take a look
i came to the states when i was 12 years
old uh i was proud by my parents and uh
we came here for the american dream to
make it happen to make it you know to
what
the whole world talks about and and that
was uh
i felt some sort of responsibility that
you know i was being brought here for a
better future
and that future was buenos aires air
conditioning and heating
carlos ava maria went into the hvac
field at just 14 years old thanks to
trade school
and by 24 he was keeping both his
business and the valley's air
conditioners
up and running here where we are
especially in las vegas uh it's not so
much a luxury
it's like a life support system we're so
dependent on how making sure that
the homes are at a certain temperature
and especially elderly or
or people with with some sort of
sickness or disease or something that
they need to make sure that they're
they're cooled buenos iris does some
commercial building services but mainly
specializes in residential homes
that includes ac repair installation
maintenance
and unit replacement we also offer
financing and stuff for unit
replacements
we make sure that your house will be the
best that it could be when it comes to
comfort
ultimately you're at your home you want
to feel the most comfortable as you can
carlos and his team also make sure their
customers feel as clean as they can
especially during a pandemic making sure
that we wear our masks that we wear
gloves and shoe covers and
we keep our distance and keep your air
quality up we use the uv
light that's one of the products to make
sure that our customers
feel good in their own home this product
protects homeowners from things like
mold
germs odors and viruses carlos how
important is it to get
maintenance done on the ac unit well
it's very important
um it's it's you got to think about this
the air conditioner is kind of like
the only mechanical piece in your home
right sort of like a car
right there's parts that move there's
skiers there's things so
a car you have to get it maintained
every so often
the same thing should be done with the
air conditioner it is very important
that the people should do it once before
the summer and once before the winter
some people may think ac maintenance is
too complicated but buenos aires makes
it easy
and affordable for our club membership
what we call it
we have five different benefits so the
checkups will be one of them we'll go
there twice a year and check the units
the discounts uh if you're a club member
you'll get 15 off
on any repairs throughout the year also
three percent off on the new
replacements uh when it comes to
priority services we guarantee that
we'll be there within 24 hours
extended warranties any of the work that
we do is comes with a two-year
warranty with extended warranties we'll
go up to three years
and then we do a condition called wash
which is one of the things that people
ask tend to ask are you going to wash
our
coils i'm going to turn this around
because this is how it flows into the
next section
it's the filtration systems now when the
customers see this they can actually see
exactly what each filter will cover
and and the prices that come along with
it as you can see the the merv 16 has
got
many many different things that it does
compared to the merv 11.
and one of them it is the uh pollutions
market and viruses
right and what's going on now this is
this is a great peace of mind
you can call buenos aires air
conditioning and heating at 702-794-2727
or
just visit their website at buenos
irasac.com and remember
their special offer they offer special
financing for new units and filters